who would you be interested in dating
from the bachelor world I think this is
the easiest question okay Tyler Cameron
we've got a lot of people agreeing with
you
and just like that Hannah and basically
broke the Internet
I mean Hannah Anne and Tyler Cameron can
you even imagine getting hot over here
this reveal was made on Thursdays Ellen
show where Sean Hayes filled in as guest
host and trust me when I say there's a
lot more Clichy skills are you currently
single yes and ready to mingle yeah
definitely ready to mingle and likely on
bachelor in paradise
are you doing bachelor in paradise there
might be a bikini waiting for me I don't
know I don't know marry who do you think
from Peters season will be the perfect
paradise contestants what women it's
already there she's already there yeah
she's in a bikini she's already on the
beach waiting there's no way with that
coronavirus she is already there she
left last night
okay so bachelor in paradise isn't even
actually filming yet but safe to say
Hannah Anne will probably be there of
course she also talked about Peter after
their pretty heartbreaking breakup
is Peter a good kisser no I don't know
about that one do you regret anything
from this experience
I don't regret loving Peter regret
trusting okay
alright it's fair enough well that's
nice of her considering so really
looking back on it our engagement
involved three women me you still be in
love with Madison and proposing to me
and you needed closure with Hannah brown
that's three women involved in our
engagement that was completely
blindsided - so word of advice if you
want to be with a woman you need to
become a real man Hannah and also talked
about Kelly showing up to after the
final rose which is weird because she
wasn't invited to the women tell all
why was Kelly after after the final rose
taping and why does she spell her name
like that next to you Kelly's one of my
good friends
I don't know I'm definitely gonna be
calling her today trying to figure that
out I got a rose taping no yeah why she
was there yeah I I don't know well we
love Kelly an important reason yeah
Kelly gonna is Kelly live near you or
she lives in Chicago why were you there
because some people thought you and
Peter would end up together they noticed
his family follows you on Instagram yeah
so from what I learned this Barb's a
huge fan she stands Kelly uh which I
just learned which is really funny but
how did you learn that because I saw her
at the finale what did she say to you
would not leave the finale until she met
me what did you and Barb say we just had
small talk but over to be honest the
majority of it was her hugging me being
like you're beautiful
and how's this for strange a certain 55
year old actor slid into Hana and GM
have any celebrity slid in your DMS
David Spade he's a slippery one slippery
or creepy I'm not too scary
anyways et was with some of bachelor
nation last night who had a bit to say
about Hannah and Madison and Peter's
journey
it's hard with everything in the ending
Hannah Ann is my girl and she absolutely
killed it I'm so proud of her and I'm
just really unsure like what's next for
Maddie and Peter and I just feel like we
didn't really get enough clothes like
what's gonna happen with them and I
don't know if it's gonna work I briefly
talked to Hannah Ann like very briefly
and I think she's doing okay I've talked
to them before the show aired and my
heart goes out to both of them it's not
an easy situation to be in and I can't
imagine what it's like so all I can do
right now is support them all right guys
that's it for today for all the latest
on bachelor nation and to see if Hannah
Ann and Tyler actually get together
stick with et until next time I'm Katie
Krause and bye for now